Learned a new card trick.
Cinematically flawless!! Hauntingly haunting!! The most-
Cinematically fl-
Cinematically flaw- Ugh
Cinematically flawless!! Hauntingly haunting!!
Cinematically flaw-
Cinematically flawless!! Hauntingly ha-
Cinematically flawless!! Hauntingly haunting!! The best horror film ever made of good- Ah, shit!
And indeed, by internet standards, tonight you will be something- Doug: You will be something scary.
Usually, when someone comes out in front of a red curtain, it's to tell you that you're about to see something scary and indeed, by- Fuck, sorry.
Doug: BY FUCK IT'S SCARY!!!
Hello!
Nope.
Nope. No, I was too into the hello.
Hi!
Usually hello.
Doug: You can say hi, that's fine too.
Doug: Malcolm you almost look intimidating, cause you're almost like,  you're shot in shadow.
Oh, really? Doug: Go back to the shot you were, just gonna hold it thank back a little bit. It's the little finger muffin. Yeah
Tamara: It is, yeah.
Doug: Kinda creepy.
"mmmmhhhhhhMMMMM"
Doug: It's you.
*laughter*
Rob: Do you care if you can clearly see that's Illinois way in the back?
I said that!
I said that, Rob.
Doug: I didn't realize what you were talkin' about.
That's why I pointed to it.
*laughter*
Malcolm: You're skin is glowing.
"Thought I was white before now you got it in stereo, baby."
"Did you do somethin' with your hair?"
I'm go- *laughter*
I'm so sorry.
"Did you do somethin' with your hair?  I'm gonna do some creepy shit over here."
*laughter*
So SORRY!
It's so funny.
"You do something with your hair? I'm gonna do some... creepy shit over here."
*laughter
Sorry.
"Yeah, even then, people are still alive in town. They must have a somewhat functional area of-"
*Doug.exe has stopped working.*
*no audible dialogue*
"My eyes!!!"
Doug: Oh, oh, you're looking right in too the sun. I'm so sorry, I didn't know that.
"I'm not looking right at it."
Doug: I didn't know! I didn't know!
Doug: *stammering* I'm sorry. I didn't know. I didn't know.
"There's only one thing we can do to act out the scene of us fighting our fears."
Si- si- Sicilians... what is it?
*laughter*
"Oh, that's just typical of you critics. Isn't it?"
Doug: Uh, Is'n TIT.
in' TIT?
Isn't iT. Isn TIT.
*under breath* Oh shit.
"No no no no no no no no. We're not going to fix past clichés, instead we're going to add-"
"We're going to-" Malcolm: Add even more? Rob: Add even more, okay.
"What?"
"She's down there!"
"Wait. What's wrong with your arm?"
"I have a cast on it."
*Laughter*
Oh, whatever.
*laughter offscreen*
Now I remember why I needed the rubber nose.